get your Poncho's ready and hold on
tight because we have the latest
creation from M night Shyamalan and
don't worry guys
this one doesn't involve trees maybe
people setting off the plants glass is
the third film in an unlikely trilogy
fusing together to thousands unbreakable
in 2016 split and as with all Shyamalan
movies glass is no exception with this
huge twist ending and this one has for
good for you so if you don't want to be
spoiled take the next train because
we're gonna get right into it and
pinpoint some of the unbreakable and
split references along the way
set shortly after the events of 2016
split James McAvoy's character or should
I say characters are still on the loose
having escaped authorities at the end of
split he has continued his obsession
with abducting young women who he needs
to sacrifice to the Beast a brutal
personality he created to mask the pain
of a father who seemingly abandoned him
leaving him with his abusive mother when
he abducts a group of cheerleaders he
once again explains that the Beast must
killed those who have not suffered
that's why Casey the main character and
split was spared by him he saw the scars
and abuse she suffered at the hands of
her uncle and therefore was unfit to be
one of the beasts many victims but these
cheerleaders on the other hand are fair
game meanwhile David Dunn the
unbreakable or as he's known in the Shia
melania universe the overseer has
started his own security company with
his son Joseph and it's the same actor
who played him 19 years ago and
unbreakable which is pretty cool not
only that but there was an entire
deleted scene from unbreakable that they
used in this movie so they didn't have
to do any of that
Robert Downey aging [ __ ] so they've
teamed up to search for the elusive
beast who's been tormenting the
neighborhood but our haunting the tales
by the cops who want to put him in jail
for his violent form of vigilante
justice in the scene where David asked
his son if he can go for a walk which is
code word for search for the bad guy
Joseph tends to a customer who appeared
at unbreakable scuse me sir his name is
Jay and it's none other than the
director Shyamalan who reprises his role
of the drug-dealing football fan who has
now turned his life around even
remembering David all those years ago
when he was frisked at the football
stadium must have been pretty memorable
he's here to pick up a security camera
after hearing one of his tenants was
killed off-site and his tenant none
other than dr. Fletcher who was
viciously squeezed to death by the Beast
and split David runs into Hedwig one of
the beasts alter egos and because of his
ability to see a person's wrongdoings is
able to track down the cheerleaders to a
nearby brick factory a battle ensues
whereby both men are caught by the
authorities and sent to a psychiatric
Institute to be evaluated by dr. Ellie
staple who has apparently survived Byrd
box it's also interesting to note her
last name staple a tool used to fix and
mend things put them back together again
dawn by a psychologist in a movie about
glass and broken people she explains to
the men that she has three days to
evaluate them whereby at which time if
she does not see them fit they'll be
sent to live the rest of their lives in
a psychiatric institution she's under
the impression that they are all
delusional that their powers are simply
figments of their imagination and she's
even able to sway both the Beast and
David to think that they maybe are in
fact crazy the bars the beasts bent and
split well they were made in the 1800s
and easy to Bent the bullets he was shot
with merely old shells that had lost
their power by the way it's pretty cool
that you can still see the bullet marks
that he gotten split in this movie dr.
staples gaslighting even works on David
who starts to believe that he may not be
who he says he is but I found this a bit
weaker since the dude can friggin lift
this and for a doctor who thinks their
powers are all in their head she sure
has gone to great lengths to
specifically design rooms that match
their weaknesses David says a tank
filled with water and the Beast has a
special set of lights that when flashed
flip his personality like a light switch
another fun fact Casey goes to the same
school Joseph went to and likely the
same one that the cheerleaders went to
as well CHS she was put into a foster
home after the events of split when she
outed her uncle who was a vicious child
molester Joseph when looking for clues
at the local comic book store is under
the villainous purple glow the color
glass always wears which is juxtaposed
to the green hero like his father's
poncho important to understanding the
ending is this struggle that goes on in
the beasts head his normal form
Kevin is being fought over by a group
called the Horde which is run by Dennis
and
Tricia they want the Beast to take over
while the others struggle to stop him
it's this inner struggle that will
eventually lead him to team up with mr.
glass who offers to break him out if he
can prove the beast is real now all mr.
glass wants is to prove to the world
that people like David and the Beast
exist
he's been deemed crazy for his beliefs
and showing the world their existence
would to him justify all the terrible
things he's done in the past like the
train derailment or a plane explosion so
he devises this crazy plan to have David
and the beasts battle at Osaka tower the
tallest building in the world on its
opening day for all the world to see but
when Joseph shows up and tells the Beast
that his father the one who mysteriously
vanished on a train years ago was killed
in the same crash David survived a crash
that was caused by mr. glass he takes
out his anger and makes short work of
the man with osteogenesis imperfecta and
yes I had to look that up how the Beast
didn't know that when Joseph was able to
easily figure it out with a quick Google
search is beyond me but he decides to
travel anyway to Osaka Tower to show the
world his powers before he stopped by KC
who is able to coax Kevin his normal
personality out of him using this time
of weakness where his body isn't immune
to bullets a team of special soldiers
under the command of dr. staples fire
and killed a beast where we have one of
the most unique death scenes in which
almost a torso of his characters get to
say their last words David on the other
hand who barely survived his battle with
the Beast in the water tank is drowned
to death by staples men but before he
passes on dr. staples reveals her true
identity to him she's part of a secret
organization whose sole duty is to bring
balance to the world and that balance
comes in eliminating anyone who shows
signs of these powers be they villain or
hero she exclaims that for 10,000 years
they've maintained this balance and all
of its members adorn three leaf clover
tattoos on their wrists now the three
leaf clover is interesting here because
it's not the four-leaf clover which we
often hear in popular culture which
represents good luck four leaf clovers
are actually considered a mutation
that's why they're so rare to find much
like how glass the Beast and David are
mutations themselves so it makes sense
that those who are killing these
mutations we're a three leaf clover and
stead of a for fun fact and the trailers
they digitally cut out the clover that
is on this shooters wrist and the method
by which this organization gets rid of
these superheroes is a reworked MRI
machine which glass somehow knows is bad
so he takes out the special magnifying
glass thingamabob er
that's meant to fry your frontal lobe
the day before his scan but just when it
seems dr. staples has successfully
covered everything up it wouldn't be a
Shyamalan movie without a real twist
ending well at a comic shop dr. staples
overhears a comic nerd exclaiming that
the real mastermind villain always has
the hero and his victims in the palm of
his hands he sets them up for the real
plan and that's exactly what mr. glass
is done he sent the camera footage of
the battle between David and the Beast
the camera footage that dr. staples
thought she had deleted to Joseph's
Casey and his mom so that it could be
sent out to the world proving the
existence of these superheroes if the
world can see this maybe others might
come out of the woodwork so the real
revolution Dennis and Patricia mentioned
can begin and the film ends in the same
train station where David honed his
empath abilities as the news of the real
mutant spreads across the world what
we're left with is a tragic ending all
of our characters dying to their own
weaknesses but in the improving not only
that they aren't delusional but a brand
new world awaits us a world filled with
possibilities I hope you like this video
guys it's my first one where I don't
actually have footage from the film
because it's not out yet so thanks for
bearing with me I have a whole bunch
more planned for January so hit that
like and subscribe button with a bell on
and remember daddy loves you very much